lock up Grandma
[Applause]
and while you're at it why not a little
girl
Shane Hoffman look girl you've been
running wild on me HBO has delivered
unto us the best post-apocalyptic show
since my wife left me please take me
back Stephanie in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into the series
comparisons to the game lore Easter eggs
and a whole lot more this is a
non-spoiler breakdown so anything beyond
episode 1 will not be discussed now make
sure to like And subscribe because I may
not always cover the shows you watch but
when I do
it's pretty sweet if you're wondering
just how bad TV was in the 1960s look no
further than ABC's Prime Time lineup of
riveting epidemiologists among them is
Dr Newman who unlike Dr schoenheis over
here who moonlights his Lurch believes
Humanity shouldn't be as concerned about
viruses or bacteria rather fungi what
fungi a fungal infection could
theoretically take over our minds use us
as hosts and spread from person to
person luckily fungi can't survive in
hosts with an internal temperature over
94 degrees the average human is 98.
however if the world's climate got
slightly warmer fungi would have to
adapt to survive fast forward 36 years
later and that's exactly what's happened
with the origin of the cordyceps brain
infection or CBI for short it's the name
of the parasitic fungus that has taken
over the world in The Last of Us in the
first few minutes of the game Sarah
Miller our protagonist's daughter picks
up a newspaper outlining its mysterious
Origins according to the Texas Herald a
mysterious infection caused by
contaminated crops imported from South
America seemed to be the culprit and if
you look very closely you can see the
date is September 26 2013. September 26
is also the date the events at the
beginning of the show take place however
the creators have changed the show
version to 2003 instead of 2013 this was
done so that when we see Joel 20 years
in the future it's 2023 and not 2033
when the events of the game take place
the show's intro credits depict this
growing fungus and as you can see it's
similar to The Game's intro our first
shot set in 2003 is an homage to the
title screen of The Last of Us
remastered of both depicting drapes
swaying in the window in the game many
of the posters for bands and movies had
to be fake for copyright reasons for
example there's the bash a Take On The
Clash which we can see HBO got the
rights to along with Destiny's Child
which would have been a huge group in
2003. both the game and TV version have
Sarah's butterfly pillow in fact
butterflies appear all throughout the
show like here in the kitchen and even
in Joel's apartment in the future
butterflies often symbolize
metamorphosis and change and if there's
a character who needs to change it's
definitely Joel but I'll get into that
in a bit even Joel's room has some fun
Easter eggs from the game from the
treadmill with a towel on the side the
painting of a moose above the bed and
even the color and style of the blanket
if this is the attention to detail the
production designers are taking with
this show it's giving me high hopes for
the rest of the season in the corner we
can see Joel's guitar case which in the
show has been replaced with a poster of
one the actual guitar will actually see
later in the living room Joel's love for
music in particular the guitar plays a
substantial thematic role in the game so
it'll be interesting how far they
incorporate this in the show unlike the
game which basically starts the night of
the infection the show eases us into the
world of 2003 Austin Texas it's Joel's
birthday and I kind of chuckled when he
said he was 36.
if you pay close attention to the radio
you can hear Dido's White Flag which
would have released two months prior in
July of 2003. its chorus has the
memorable line I will go down with this
ship a sitting song considering what's
about to happen we also hear a news
report of quote disturbances in Jakarta
it's unclear if this has anything to do
with the infection or with the clashes
the Indonesian military had with
separatists that year yes I'm a big nerd
Sarah's shirt is the same from the game
and features a fake band named halicon
drops which is said to be named after a
doll of one of the Creator's daughters
notice to the purple color so far Sarah
Tess and Ellie all women that are close
or will become close to Joel have worn
these colors purple symbolizes among
other things spiritual growth and Joel
has a lot of growing to do if he's going
to grow as a character we also learned
that Joel and his brother Tommy seem to
be contractors in the game they are
carpenters and you might be asking
yourself where is Joel's wife in the
game we don't know much about her just
that whatever occurred between them is
too painful to talk about and that she
left him shortly after Sarah was born
leaving him to raise her on his own
meanwhile Sarah borrows her father's
broken watch and some money to surprise
him for his birthday by having it fixed
later stating you were never gonna do it
for yourself so this is especially true
in the future when he has that same
watch damaged and still unfixed from the
night of Sarah's murder it's like he
wears a constant reminder of her death
everywhere he goes what I found really
interesting here is the amount of time
spent on this knife with horses engraved
on it at this time I've only seen the
first episode but knowing how much Ellie
loves her switchblade I put my money on
Joel gifting this to her in the future
next door the adlers and their invalid
mother Connie this is a new addition to
the show and later shows us just how
this fungal infection can transform
someone who's wheelchair bound into a
bloodthirsty Maniac on the back of
Tommy's Car is an Operation Desert Storm
veteran bumper sticker Tommy was never
in Desert Storm in the game so it'll be
interesting to see how this plays out in
the show for those interested the old
iron sides are the first Armored
Division of the US Army there's also a
fun moment where Joe tells Tommy to put
out his cigarette when in the future
Joel will risk his life getting
cigarettes in order to radio Tommy well
it wouldn't be Texas without old George
W on the wall the president in 2003. I
thought this scene was pretty funny
considering the teacher is teaching them
about adverbs something she says they'll
definitely need later in life kind of
like when my algebra teacher said my
YouTube career would go nowhere and to
get back to doing my polynomials at the
clock shop Sarah gets Joel's watch
repaired before being shoot out cop cars
fire trucks and SWAT are swarming the
city and something is definitely up time
has played an important role in The Last
of Us games with its major acts split
into seasons in the first half of this
episode almost every scene has a clock
that tells us the time from when Sarah
wakes up at 708 am the clock at school
or when she awakes to the sound of
explosions at 2 16 a.m Sarah pays a
visit to Mrs Adler their home is adorned
with Bibles pictures of Jesus and even
an organ no doubt to play hymns that
haunted me as a child people out there
need to get right with Jesus even their
dog is named Mercy ironic since their
family is killed in the most merciless
manner Sarah is on the lookout for a
premium DVD remember those in part
particular Curtis and Viper too because
what Christian loving home doesn't have
an ultra violent action film in the game
we learned Joel is really into these
films what movie you guys gonna watch
what's Joel into
uh Curtis and Viper 2. later in the
episode we'll even see a worn out Curtis
and Viper 2 poster in Boston scarier
than the DVD of Franklin plays hockey or
the fact murder ball is here which
didn't come out until 2005 is Connie in
the background acting very strange
she'll eventually succumb to the fungi
infection and it's briefly mentioned
that she may have picked this up in the
city while on one of her many hospital
visits overhead fighter jets scramble
and here I am trying to figure out if
this was the actual September 2003 issue
of 17 magazine here's the actual October
2003 issue which would have come out in
September and it has the same title get
great style but a different cover why do
I bring this up no reason I'm just an
insane person late from work Jules
forgot the cake he was supposed to get
for his birthday regardless he and Sarah
celebrate and she gives him that
repaired watch in the game it's a
completely new watch their time however
is cut short when Jewel receives a call
from Tommy in jail he was in yet another
bar fight and needs his big bro to bail
him out because if if he doesn't do it
tonight he'll be there all weekend
because it's a Friday and yes September
26 2003 did land on a Friday Tommy isn't
featured heavily in this episode however
we're starting to get a picture of what
he's like an ex-military vet with
pent-up anger who drinks a bit too much
and is quick to use force with her
father out picking up Tommy Sarah
awakens to explosions and helicopters
whirring overhead the TV alerts everyone
to stay indoors so obviously Sarah's not
going to do that she checks in on the
adlers to make the gruesome discovery
that Grandma Connie has had one too many
of those raisin cookies this is our
first sighting of an infected what I
found really interesting and creepy here
were the tentacle like tendrils coming
out of her mouth which seemed to Aid in
providing sustenance to its host body
it's it's gross as hell luckily Joel and
Tommy arrive in the nick of time to put
Grandma down and absolutely
gut-wrenching scene Tommy somehow has a
gun but I chalked that up to him being a
good old Texas boy in their escape from
Austin we really get to see who Joel is
as a character ignoring families who
need help on the side of the road and my
favorite leaving his neighbors to get
eaten then he should get back inside the
house you lock your doors now a few
moments later
in the video game version it's not
Grandma who's killed but their neighbor
Jimmy
the show has a little nod to Jimmy when
they pass the burning Farmhouse God it's
Jimmy's Place in the game this building
belongs to a guy named Lewis that's
Lewis's Farm there are some amazing
almost shot for shot moments from the
game here and as someone who absolutely
loves the game it brought me tremendous
Joy nothing brings me joy anymore not
even food this entire sequence is
chaotic the armies block the highway
they're Unsure how the virus spreads and
cell phone and radios are all down the
plan as it stands is to go through town
past the golf course by the river and
pick up the highway past the southern
blockade going into town was not the
best idea I love how a film called
Midnight Madness is playing in the
theater as panicked theater goers
Stampede out in this episode's
background actor award goes to this
woman who is so creepy just standing
there throughout the chaos a slight
departure from the game is the addition
of this massive airplane crash which
sends what appears to be some shrapnel
through the car as the camera cuts to
Black in the game version their car gets
T-boned but the outcome is the same Joel
and surrogate cut off from Tommy and
Sarah can't walk forcing Joel to carry
her they're soon chased by an infected
and noticed the markings on his face
they're very similar to the ones found
on Ellie after she informs Tess and Joel
that she's resistant to the infection
but we'll get more into that in a bit
these infected are insanely fast and
luckily for Joel and Sarah the one hot
in their tails is killed by a soldier
what follows is almost identical in both
versions the soldier gets the order to
kill Joel and Sarah fearing they could
be infected the soldier shoots Tommy
kills him but it's too late Sarah is
killed in the process this is arguably
the most important moment in all of The
Last of Us Part 1 as it shapes Joel into
the man he becomes and provides the
backbone for his relationship with Ellie
it's hard for Joel to get close to
people because he knows the pain of
having to lose them this is why we'll
see his relationship with Ellie start
off as transactional she's cargo and
that's it 20 years later we're in
post-apocalyptic Boston which looks
slightly better than what it looks like
now a boy collapses on the outskirts of
the walled off quarantine Zone which is
manned by fedra or federal Disaster
Response agency the ruling Authority
Amalgamated with the U.S military to
oversee these quarantine zones like in
the game humans are tested with these
CBI scanners to see if they're infected
and this boy gets rid indicating he's
infected it's likely the boy caught this
by whatever injured him in the leg Joel
will later dispose of this boy's body
showing almost no emotion that part of
him has long since been buried I also
like the signs which litter the qz such
as signs of cordycep infection including
coughing slurred speech muscle spasms
and mood change so basically every time
I drink this one however is really
interesting showing how long it takes
for the infection to spread depending on
where you've been bitten neck and face
five to ten minutes torso arms shoulders
and hands 2-8 hours and legs and feet
roughly 12 to 24 hours this is important
considering Ellie is said to have been
exposed to the infection three weeks ago
and yet she's fine this is why she's
tasked daily with counting to 10 and
doing some other menial tasks to test
her cognitive function seven eight
U Joel undertakes a series of odd jobs
for these ration cards in the game we
see people lining up to exchange these
cards and Boston is currently undergoing
its third week of half rations it looks
as though there are several different
colored cards which designate the amount
of rations the game also gives us a
better glimpse of this walled off
quarantine Zone Boston is under with a
fireflies call authoritarian rule by
fedra they have enforced curfews guards
atop the buildings keeping an eye on
everyone and even public executions the
irony here is that the executions take
place in Boston's North Square where
founding fathers like Paul Revere lived
and espoused the virtues of freedom and
liberty we can briefly see some red
graffiti being clean that states the
Firefly motto when you're lost in the
darkness look for the light it's
interesting then that the first shot of
Ellie is her bathed in light will later
be introduced to the fireflies at
revolutionary militia group intent on
taking down Federer's authoritarian
control more on that in a bit Joel is
also a Smuggler establishing a network
of contexts to get certain in-demand
items one such contact as a federal
soldier who he sells drugs to in
exchange for ration cards and cigarettes
but Joel is planning something a little
more elaborate he wants a truck but the
problem is this guy can only get him a
shitty one without a battery this is
where Robert comes in Joel's partner in
crime Tess paid Robert for a battery but
he ended up taking the money and trying
to sell the battery to the fireflies
something that does not go well for him
in the game it's not a battery at all
but weapons you think Robert still got
our guns for his sake he better after
his talk with the federal Soldier we see
Joel with the Firefly logo in front of
him Joel is a man who is lost in the
darkness and Ellie is his metaphorical
light Tess here has been mistakenly beat
up by Robert's men this is not good for
Robert who knows she's close with Joel
who he's scared of in the game Robert
plays a larger role essentially becoming
the game's first antagonist their tattoo
is wrecked when an explosion lands tests
in the middle of a crossfire between the
fireflies and fedra she'll later be
picked up by Frederick soldiers and
released our first meeting with Ellie or
if you prefer her fake name Veronica
shows just how feisty she is she's being
held captive by the fireflies after they
caught her escaping a federal facility
for orphaned children if you want to
know more about what happened to Ellie
before she got here check out the
American Dreams graphic novel and he
left behind DLC which go over how Ellie
got bitten and into Firefly custody but
for the purposes of this video all you
really need to know is that she was
bitten and she is somehow immune other
than these markings around the area of
infection action she has no other side
effects so Ellie is extremely valuable
as she may be the key to unlocking a
cure also I like how this woman has duct
tape on her belt one of the key crafting
components in the game those cigarettes
have come in handy as Joel's able to
skip that line at the local radio
operator this seems to be one of a few
modes of communication with limited
access for people within Boston Joel's
hoping a message has come from his
brother Tommy who is currently in
Wyoming it's now been three weeks
without any messages from Tommy and he's
used to at least getting a response
within a day this is why Joel is so
adamant to get that truck he believes
Tommy is in trouble after Downing
copious amounts of pills and whiskey for
me a typical Friday night we see how
Joel is still haunted by the death of
his daughter hearing her screams in his
sleep Tess comes and Cuddles up with him
in bed in the game the two of some
flirty banter but it's never known if
their intimacy manifests as far as it
does in the show it's like we're on a
date well I am the romantic type at the
Firefly headquarters we meet Marlene the
head of operations here in Boston her
compatriots want answers on why they're
attacking seemingly meaningless targets
and why on Earth do they have a random
girl chained up Marlene will later pass
Kim a message from the radio tower in
Salem we never see what it says but it's
likely confirmation that Ellie has a
mutated form of the infection and is
indeed immune those random attacks
aren't random at all Marlene wants to
divert attention away from their
location so that a squadron of her men
can escort Ellie out of the city in
exchange for some ration cards Tess
finds out Robert's location she and Joel
intend on getting their battery one way
or another Joel's even approached by a
firefly member looking to have him join
the cause but Joel is a lone wolf but if
you're feeling lost tell me to look for
the light and I'll break your jaw Ellie
has given her backpack back from Marlene
in it is a switchblade that used to
belong to her mother Anna not much is
known about Anna even little about her
father but Marlene befriended her mother
before Ellie was born and promised to
protect Ellie after she died giving
birth with Marlene had the fireflies a
very dangerous position she gave Ellie
to the fedra orphanage where she would
be much safer and could keep an eye on
her there's a brief moment where Ellie
calls the fireflies Terrace and Marlene
shoots back with was Riley a terrorist
in the Left Behind DLC Riley is Ellie's
best friend who was a firefly I won't
spoil what happens to her but with them
using the past tense here you can take a
guess it's here Marlene tells Ellie
about her immunity and the fireflies
plans for her meanwhile Joel and Tess
make the dangerous Trek to Robert's
location and uncover a dead cordycep
this is somewhat similar to the Dead one
they uncover in the game who is a lot
more fresh upon reaching their
destination they find out it's the
Firefly headquarters and the deal
between robertsmen and the fireflies has
gone sour leaving many dead and Marlene
shot what's worse the car battery is no
good and out of nowhere Ellie tries to
stab Joel like
Marlene and Joel have assorted past with
Joel believing Marlene was instrumental
in turning his brother against him but
with bedra Shirley on the way and Joel
nowhere closer to getting out of the
city an interesting Arrangement is
proposed if Joel and Tess deliver Ellie
to the Old State House they'll provide
him with anything he needs for his trip
fueled up truck weapons supplies the
whole nine yards Jolin tests never
deliver human cargo but they need this
and decide to make an exception back at
Joel's apartment Ellie snoops around as
Joel and test aside the next course of
action inside Billboard's number one hit
books Ellie finds a note containing a
Smuggler's coat when a song from the 60s
plays it means there's nothing in the
70s New Stock and 80s and X Ellie will
later trick Joel into divulging what an
80 song means by telling him a song
played while he was sleeping that was
from the 80s judging by his look 80's
song means trouble the final part of
this note is this BF BF referring to
Bill and Frank the two men Joel
communicates with we haven't met him yet
but Bill is played by Nick Offerman and
apparently there's a whole episode
devoted to him and his backstory Ellie's
never been outside the quarantine Zone
her entire life which is why she's so
amazed to take everything in when they
reach the outer walls unfortunately
they're busted by the same Federal
soldier who warned Joel that there would
be extra patrols out considering the
uptick in Firefly Attacks he uses his
CBI scanner to detect them but Ellie
stabs him in the process allowing Joel
to unleash Decades of Rage after this
situation conjures in him flashes of the
night Sarah was murdered I guess Ellie
now knows what Joel is capable of what
are they capable of reaching for the
scanner Tess finds out that Ellie is
infected but Ellie tells them that the
bite happened three weeks ago and no one
lives past a day this is what makes
Ellie so special she's immune and with
the sounds of fedra soldiers quickly
approaching the team makes their way
into the contaminated Zone as Depeche
Mode's 1987 song never let me down plays
as we know an 80s song means trouble and
something tells me these guys are
heading straight for it now I turn it
over to you what did you think of the
first episode of The Last of Us if you
haven't already be sure to like And
subscribe I plan on covering every
episode and you'll want to stick around
for that for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
look girl you've been running wild on me